What's the move?
We lead our boys through it.
So, you'll write me?
A girl worth writing to
is hard to find.
Not if you know where to look.
I'm gonna miss you every second.
Major Egan,
you were the first pilot
assigned to the 100th.
Me and Buck Clevin.
You are in charge of 35 planes
and 350 air crewmen.
Don't you die on me
before I get over there.
Something big is brewing.
The eighth will be sending up
the largest air armada
ever assembled
in the history of mankind.
Straight into Hitler's territory.
We need complete
and total air superiority.
That's the mission.
What?
You might be the last
pretty face I ever see.
I'm hit! I'm hit!
Three's going down!
What's the move?
We lead our boys through it.
All that we do…
day in, day out,
does something to a guy,
doesn't it?
We're here to fight the monsters.
The things these people
are capable of…
They got it coming.
Trust me.
Lord, guard and guide
the men who fly
through the great spaces
of the sky.
Are we Tuskegee men, or what?!
Sir, yes sir!
Be with them traversing the air,
in darkening storms…
or sunshine fair.
I think we may be done!
We are gonna sit here
and take it!
We're gonna
stick with our mission
as long as we can fly.
We won't go without a fight.